my favorite feature of the amazing pixel
book the first one that google came out
with they sent me one for free i never
knew who sent it to me
um you know i don't know if it was pr or
sergey or larry but it just showed up at
my office one day
it had the most amazing feature which
was built in
uh 4g
at the time and i think they used att
verizon and i turned it on
what an amazing experience to open your
laptop and just have it connected do you
have a chiclet expansion card that
allows me to put my google phi sim in
there my data sim in there yet right
that's not something we have today but
that is absolutely the type of expansion
card that we had in mind as we built
this like you know really is that every
individual user has a different set of
needs and there's no way to build a one
size fits all machine you've got to be
able to allow for that end user
customization
now why not put
six of those chiclet expansion cards
into the laptop sure i mean ultimately
there's you know design trade-offs that
you take any time you build a hardware
product um in this case like
going from from four we're actually all
four of these have exactly equal
capabilities you can do video output
power in and out on any of these ports
we went to six we would have had to
start to make some of those things
behave differently we would have had to
compromise on things like maybe battery
capacity or speaker quality
uh and just as we mentioned before you
can get an hp chromebook
uh for 89 on amazon right
uh now that's on sale it's usually 190
but the idea of one laptop per child
they did push the market to
come up with that same solution so
mission accomplished there
now okay
if somebody's listening to this saying
okay these expansion ports i can do that
with a dongle i could just have dongle
life which
is brutal i carry like a little purse
with me right now wherever i go i got a
man purse i got a murse with dongles in
it and all my little things which is
quite nice when
you know i'm on a vacation and
somebody's like i need to and i'm like
oh and i pull out my little merce and
i'm like what do you need you need
lightning to usbc you need usbc to
ethernet i got everything
but
um there are other features here what
else can i change about my
laptop if i choose to go with framework
sure yeah so in addition to the
expansion cards uh there are parts but
they're actually just cosmetically
customizable and so like the display
bezel for example instead of being glued
on is just magnet attached and part of
the reason for that was to make it easy
to replace the display like not needing
to replace you know half the laptop if
you've you know cracked your display
somehow
but it also just enables this really
simple cosmetic customization so i've
got i don't know if folks can see it but
i've got a gray bezel on this one we've
got an orange one and some other colors
in development wow so the bezel comes
off and it's magnetized what a brilliant
innovation
so
i have an ipad i crack the screen
something goes wrong i bring it to apple
they're like yeah you cracked your
screen i'm like no [ __ ]
and i'm like well can you fix it they're
like yeah it's 800 to fix it i'm like
it's a 400 ipad and it's three years old
and they're like yeah
i'm like well i could buy a new ipad for
that they're like yeah buy a new one
right there
and you can't repair anything so what
you're telling me here is hey if i break
this i can fix it no problem right uh
yeah or apple says okay yeah come back
in three weeks
right that's right
um you can also i see when you order it
it comes with a screwdriver that's right
send people a screwdriver
you can look for it if you want yeah
but i think we know what a screwdriver
looks like
um what what is the screwdriver do it
lets you open it up and and see the
motherboard and then what can i change
about that that's right so you can
actually change
yeah so every part of the machine is is
upgradable replaceable using that single
tool that we ship in the box and so you
basically unscrew the five fasteners at
the bottom pull off the input cover and
then everything's just a single layer
you know nothing's buried under anything
else and part of the reason for this as
well was that you know if you've got you
know flaky key on your keyboard or you
know you spilled something or even want
to like change your keyboard language
you can do that just by swapping out
either the keyboard itself that screws
into the back of this or
this cover piece which is you know much
simpler to replace what would it cost to
replace a keyboard
uh so something like a keyboard you know
it's like 40 or 50 dollars we're
actually just about to start making
replacement ones available through our
web store
and does this all mean that if let's say
some maniac wants to create a keyboard
that's a little more
clicky for writers and coders they could
make one for the framework laptop
without your permission or they have to
come to you and get your permission how
are you thinking about the extensibility
of this with other partners right so i
mean as we look at things like expansion
cards we've actually already released
the design files openly on actually on
github and just under an open license so
anyone including like an individual
hobbyist can go pull down the reference
designs pull down the cad develop their
own card and prototype it and even
resell it out to additional folks if
there's interest in the community we've
seen some like really interesting
designs coming up already
but then as we look at the rest of the
machine that is actually the goal here
we want every part of this to be
something that we can develop an
ecosystem around and not be you know not
be asking users just to rely on us at
framework to cover the entire broad
range of needs that are out there
wow so
uh the first thing i thought of when i
saw your chicklet and expansion slots
was wouldn't it be interesting if
somebody made one where i tap it and it
slides out a thumb reader like a
biometric yeah now you may not be in the
biometric business but there's got to be
a hundred companies who already have
built biometrics
who would build this for you for 30
bucks and then i could use my thumb to
unlock everything and authenticate
you're saying you are giving that
business away for free to the rest of
the world to innovate on this platform
yeah that's right actually we do have a
fingerprint reader built into the the
power button on the laptop but yeah
definitely you know things like
biometrics are things that you could
develop an expansion card around well i
mean the other one is for people who
really care about security i've always
wondered why gps is not included right
uh n5g so if you had 5g and gps now your
laptop which is you know a very
important piece of equipment if it was
stolen like find your ipad
you could have it
when it's in lost mode you know or every
15 minutes
just
turn on the 5g connection and say it's
location so if somebody were to steal it
and you could put a dead man switch on
it people don't know what that is the
dead man switches
if you're driving a train and you you
push down to make the train go if you
have a heart attack you fall down right
your hand is no longer pushing down the
throttle it stops so you could have a
dead man switch which if i don't use my
laptop
24 hours it starts beaconing every
minute that's right yeah you know the
location covertly and then turns on the
camera and the microphone and starts
recording and sending you clips sure
yeah it's all like whoever stole it yeah
or you know on security things like
two-factor authentication or nfc or you
know other things like that that's all
possible as an expansion card
we all know how hard it is to eat
healthy when you're grinding on product
sprints and trying to meet crazy
deadlines well now there's an innovative
food company trying to help
real good foods is one of the fastest
growing frozen food brands in the us
they're making nutritious foods more
accessible to improve human health and
they make all the food you love mexican
italian breakfast sandwiches pizzas and
more everything is 100 grain free low in
carbs high in protein and best part made
from real food ingredients they are
available in the freezer section of
costco walmart target and 90 percent of
grocery stores nationwide when i found
out about them i went into my instacart
i went out to amazon they were
everywhere and we've been eating the
pizza it's delicious plus you can get
them delivered same day by instacart
real good foods is healthy convenient
and tasty it's perfect for any lifestyle
plus part of their mission is to support
food banks across the us and they have a
goal of donating one million nutritious
meals nicely done real good foods so go
to realgoodfoods.com and use the code
twist for 15 off
learn more and follow at real good foods
on social media or go
realgoodfoods.com and use that code
twist to get 15 off